here's the thing in terms of fitness I
don't know if our la contingent are
aware of this man he's called Craig
Ramsay do you know Craig Ramsay he's
come up with these basically in our busy
lifestyle he the silence there was
absolute silence after you said his name
you don't so I'll tell you so an e is
invasive fitness expert and he's come up
with all these workouts you can do in
five minutes and there's no matter what
you're doing so for instance in the
office you can work out these are just
ways I use a printer when you can create
vine left in front left behind
[Music]
when you're
[Applause]
manicure pedicure
ninety-eight nice smelling and finishing
off with grace and style even one even
in the car wash
give it in the car wash your detail a
snack car keys everybody light touches
it's important to take care of the
interior and exterior
[Applause]
brilliant I just wonder has he got a nap
so anyway we've been in touch with them
to see if there were any easy exercises
we could do in a chat show formation I
just have a bit wider it might have a
stroke in case I die on television I
love my husband I love my kids and
goodbye you can get a refund for the
Wimbledon theatre right now Grammys on
skype now I think hello hi hello Graham
hi
[Applause]
we've
exercises so far now have you come up
with ones that we can do on the show
without people noticing just just
quickly well let me explain the exercise
I'm going to give you today program can
anywhere else not hear him we can all
hear him you have had a stroke
[Applause]
if you have an exercise for the couch
break absolutely what a fit and fabulous
Bunch
all right let's bring our booty to the
front of that couch
ya know are there we go chair lean back
a little bit hold on for dear life
yeah those legs oh yeah
good girl and my naughty girl you know
you haven't been to America yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you